du sport à présent et du sport pour la
bonne cause en l'honneur de maele une
jeune mort parce vienne atteinte de
leucémie et gala de basket était
organisée dimanche par le club local
vous le voyez à l'image le public était
au rendez vous entre dribbler entracte
rythmée par de la danse tout était pensé
pour sortir mal de son quotidien comme
nous l'expliquent une joueuse du club de
mort pas écouté la une journée festive
et on a voulu associer sa voix là avec
une petite cagnotte une petite entrée
participative à partir de 1 euro
histoire ben voilà que la somme qui sera
récoltée la famille pour en disposer
comme elle veut et vraiment les aider à
passer des moments meilleur dans cette
épreuve qu'est la maladie
on est de tout coeur derrière la famille
de mails derrière mais elle m'a il sert
de notre fille aussi donc on est de tout
coeur avec elle